it's national beer lovers day which
means tomorrow should be national
hangover day but it's not on the
calendar have you ever had a hazed and
infused it'd be a lot cooler if you did
this Dazed and Confused inspired fruity
tasting brew comes from Colorado's very
first craft brewery boulder beer company
next up is a six percent brownell from
Dogfish Head Brewing Company this Star
Trek themed beer was forced to change
its name from ratha pecan to pecan
because a Liquor Authority noticed there
weren't any actual hakansson it is very
cool number three is holy grail l not
only does it roll off your tongue but
you can easily pour it right down your
throat because it's only four percent
alcohol this beer was specially
commissioned to commemorate the 30th
anniversary of Monty Python in 1999
Imperial Stout trooper this beers nine
percent alcohol so make sure you keep
your helmet on while drinking thanks to
the New England Brewing Company the dark
side has a lot of power we saved our top
spot for an entire brewing company
cinema brewers out of the Netherlands
has produced hits like bought to the
future King Kong and our favorite the
pulp fiction inspired five dollar shake
it's a perfect pairing for a Royale with
cheese let us know if we left off any of
your favorites and enjoy national beer
lovers day responsibly by drinking
behind a mess of pre freaking good
milkshake told him no this worth I'd I
was pretty good